you know what really sucks us
I'm not playing well okay but I mean I
got like winning positions every other
game yeah even with this by simple means
like him
I will I actually don't need to berserk
I just need to win the games that I
should win and I don't not the last I
don't know 40 minutes or so I haven't
won a game in ages and I had fantastic
positions
yeah this is again it looks fantastic
yellow to cool up hmm yeah I'm basically
well oh my god he resigned he resigned
I want a game first one for ages
okay go Jerry okay
[Music]
he cannot take that's 95 I cannot take
unfortunately
he keeps playing quickly
33 seconds
and we never knew things on time as
usual I always lose on time against him
I have winning positions every game and
I was on time it's just what it is yeah
maybe I shouldn't have repaid be berserk
because it's told the city to berserk
and much stronger player what he did
actually anyway ok Blade Runner
you can try it's not so terrible
I don't do question at some moment that
much to where three at the sill against
the Sicilian a of course but some that's
not too bad because I'm not going
berserk against those guys because I
play like crap at the moment I just want
to get to get games and get some flow
again maybe I should does work I don't
know maybe this is the wrong decision
yeah I should really get a streak going
yeah not on the first page is pretty
awful
okay I have a piece of for not much and
I got some good points can I win this I
guess I can once look very dangerous I
shouldn't I shouldn't now stare me down
can't melt my next one b2 or b3 okay
10th place let me at least like top 3 I
mean that that should be possible I
don't really care much about the ratings
those guys have I'm I'm in good shape I
should should fight for the win in this
event but well it doesn't happen not a
good not a good run him ok ok let's see
what happens him it's a bit of a
sicilian type of position with reversed
colors white is just going for it don't
know is that good before it's not a
great idea that's made on g7 I came
okay really wonder is that is that good
what he knows is doing here you ready
for now okay just class bank therefore
taking hmm I don't know taking is
probably right and play against e4 pawn
this maybe I should have played Nigel
deform when I had the possibility he
might now prevent it let's do it okay
ninety f3 chick so I don't really see
his attack going anywhere now and I
should be fine
should be fine him he's not taking it no
he does so we can check here it this
should still be okay after the rook is
hanging rook f2 coming as an idea at
least
it looks awkward very awkward but how do
I win okay that is easy
so take things goes to check on each
five there's something better than
taking yeah anyway I have to do this
and now this check and now if I go here
queen is six king h5 and there's not
check anymore
I don't see a check our queen h6 I
overlooked Queen h6
crazy and crazy I'd take him
don't check right I don't see chick
rook takes g3 Bishop takes g3 is that I
would like to win this just by checking
that would be good
yeah nobody can take with the look
there's just 25 and then King age four
and that's it
oh that's chicken
somehow it still feels like dodging
bullets
aha no I'm just going to beat you now
don't deserve back no King it's
fantastic
oh my god okay okay at least it's
somewhat playable position it's not
completely bad ah it's not good either
but
they're just not good just not good
yeah I know easy stuff in a mouse lip
now that was terrible really terrible
more slip okay ah bad yeah I don't
bizarre back I just don't play quick
enough him at the moment
yeah it's well played by him doesn't
have any issues at all just a college
position
better him that looks good
that looks good looks very controlled do
this I don't believe this [ __ ]
come on come on that's crazy this is
crazy
it was completely winning of course no I
never under in one move yeah and he sees
it of course what a pest is tournament
is no really crazy that's crazy
[Laughter]
really really weird never texted five
wasn't losing camp on ending it didn't
help anymore I heard it I couldn't just
do whatever we can just do whatever not
just not this yeah it was the only way
to spoil this friggin game
um there was very little chance of
lagging really
okay yeah this is okay for me but
probably nothing special got the bishop
pair and white has reasonable reasonably
good pieces of course
so I capture converse is six by five
when 95 comes and put the bishop on to
d5 that would be good
okay so I have got this I was single
night before yeah it looks a bit a bit
Sun bit awkward in terms of winning I
mean it's just nothing going on but I
probably cannot win
even though dr. bishop a I cannot do
much him
and losing that game against Jerry was
kind of really unnecessary really
unnecessary now open some lines is good
idea but it's not not easily done I
declined to draw and not because I
wanted I just saw it today
that is probably a draw just so sorry
too late could have accepted earlier I
mean I want 84 points this is fun I've
been on 84 for ages okay
Dominic W and then he gets free in Mouse
slips and things yeah this is really
really awkward
it's not be hectic okay so yeah yeah I
can't do a couple of things that I
interesting this is one of them let's
see what Dominic is doing it was the
idea of the whole thing
oh okay
can you try to trap it my night I mean I
cannot chick and I didn't have squares
it's a bit awkward
mmm how do I do this I don't see a
really good move he's got Roxy seven
coming
maybe Bishop g4 or something
I don't see a really clean finish to
this queen f1 that was probably a good
idea that sheeting if I do that now
maybe a little bit
okay checking it isn't it doesn't do all
that much King g8 nothing nothing
special coming
look everyone maybe I just would need to
get my knight somehow into the game like
this no I have six the threat it looks
pretty good pretty good
probably has two SEC the exchange
it's a a way to avoid that Queen e2 M
Knight f6 checking if eight tried to
survive that okay so I take it the
ending is winning but isn't this
stronger I think this is stronger
[Music]
the weird thing is I feel like I could
actually screw that out the way I'm
doing this at the moment is really crazy
okay so it should work there was a UH
yeah I know a copy until the end I know
the pretty pretty good line it was a
check I don't think I overlooked the
made in one only one
justice bought this is extremely
irritating all of those nights going on
over the place help
it's Buddha chess basically after the
after the Boozer King Queen rook e1 or
something yeah I don't have super great
squares yeah Knights are extremely
irritating I agree I almost made I have
a silly move actually good money to me
they have to be careful it's a drone of
course when I run into the mid I run
into the friggin maid and saw it before
yeah I saw I perform and then you it was
kind of it was kind of infamy yeah I saw
it before and then still yeah I cannot I
cannot play bullet after three and a
half hours of this chances that's really
I shouldn't try it shouldn't try it I
just don't have any sort of problem
perception of the board
[Music]
yeah I shouldn't buzzer really it
doesn't work I mean I can't do it
sometimes if I'm absolutely in good
shape but it just doesn't work if I'm
tired
I'm completely lost again yeah Byam
playing and not thinking okay I have to
ever you have to do play sharper
otherwise I'm not going into getting
anywhere just to get awake again or
something hey coffee I don't have coffee
this is at least somewhat interesting
yes some of those followers I don't
really want to pronounce
okay so it's a reasonably quiet position
no it's not situ actually a threat maybe
[Music]
don't know that is actually a threat and
what I cannot play it no it's good I'm
really playing with crab Queen b3 what
am I doing here come on this is getting
really embarrassing I'm really not such
a terrible player but I played terrible
chess Queen b3 was also a big issue but
this is probably enough that's crazy
absolutely crazy in flame
[Music]
he was straightening 9339 night is 3m is
really we had such a great run and then
all of a sudden it's it's just it's just
gone it's just completely gone I have no
nothing really weird really weird
I don't know I don't think it's due to
somebody joining the stream or anything
that that's certainly not the case what
what to do here
53 I can take on a threesome that's not
great
c4 he might want to play a doubling here
cannot be too bad
yeah thanks for the kind words yeah I
probably those tournaments are just a
bit too long I came I have this the best
bishop on a7 is really terrible I have
to get that somehow into the game
maybe taking an f5 is an idea
yeah I see a lot of money because I
don't need shampoo that's true but
instead after by all those shaving
equipment that's also quite costly I
hope I'm not disconnected
I wonder why customer not playing is
that such a terribly difficult decision
here or no
going for h5 next
and try to win even more get even more
space use the King so I wonder am if I
take everything there guess that is a
good choice
probably not my night is not well
positioned I have to reroute it somehow
he wants to go to Sephora hmm
[Music]
hmm I don't see what to do this is the
thing I don't think this position is bad
but I don't see a good solution try to
play on the g4 maybe I don't know
somehow other side c4 is a good good
thing for him my bishop is bad
[Music]
just blinded us in one move great that's
so great
in one move just in one that must be fun
to watch share some I am playing like
like a beginner for three hours or
something on two hours but I have to
hang in there really weird still on 12th
place but with someone reasonable player
could easily be third or something
and I was totally fine in that position
when I blended everything it makes it
that makes it worse okay at least others
make some weird mistakes as well
now I'm not alone yeah I really don't
already wonder hmm there are even longer
tournaments how they how they do those
hmm okay okay now we get into them
really wacky stuff hmm I don't know it
said what is that it's that good I don't
think it is good but don't ask me why
and how and due to what exactly
I really have no idea
[Music]
this is some extremely wacky so where do
I go we am from g5 maybe 95 95 we'd have
to keep in mind that is actually a
pretty decent player he's got a somewhat
normal rating the the fact that he
places his weird opening doesn't mean he
sees a pizza
okay
it's the weirdest ever that's fire
I have two pieces up in this position so
I should just play aggressively use the
pieces okay rook f8 maybe push the Queen
first that makes sense yes got to check
think this first 494 I'm not really
interested in the material
okay now now he has absolutely no attack
I think and now I'm attacking so we'll
check here or this first is okay
okay well that worked well so a decent
maybe again justice but like yeah this
is this is if he knows this I'm in
trouble because it's super complicated
and I have no I don't remember 93 years
to move
okay made only aid is an idea which is
so consolidating
forty-three seconds is kind of okay
Scottie's get some get some chicken okay
okay I will five pointer at least yes
would thank you okay
yeah William Wallace maybe we can get a
classic union going did I screw up the
moose order maybe I did it looks a bit
iffy actually for me no not the best
move water whatever I played him
at least there was somewhat quick yeah I
don't know how bad that really is he's
got some play down
[Music]
it's probably not that grade 26 it looks
really really weird somehow like it
blunder stuff but maybe not will seem if
you move the bishop f24 that's a nice
little trick
oh thanks for subscribing Gilly Bigelow
[Music]
yeah Harry Joseph is crazy ahead him by
and by a mile really ok what is this
so extremely tricky this position
extremely tricky
I also threatened Luke evade sometimes
the back rank is an issue
yeah that looks very good for me and
he's pretty much letting the clock run
down
lucozade maybe
[Music]
I think it winds the crank and now maybe
Knight to g4 yeah
going from made on edge to it's probably
g3
yeah it's a pretty normal view account
close to 200 the question was how much
viewers do I usually get this is fairly
normal number ok night scene idea of to
check coming don't really have to
reinvent the wheel him ok so ok some
some points there 2 2 5 4 looks decent
ok let's go up say Ronnie Ronnie 30 I
shouldn't do any wacky mouse lips like I
have one again
I was pretty awful
pretty pretty awful I still have teeth I
prepared this really thoroughly just
Network it Jerry Jerry's over the board
wedding is like 2200 but he he never
plays yeah he really really rarely plays
any tournaments I think and he's a lot
stronger and blitz especially online I
think I mean I don't know I don't know
how his blitz is over the boy I was a
city remark but he is very strong in
online plaits especially bullet you know
I've had my fair share of experience
with them over the years and in blitz I
usually win pretty clearly but
five-minute but everything quicker hmm
yeah Jerry is really strong so should to
deform me so good position for me but
still difficult to play very difficult
to play yeah the question is do I
actually react to that f4 bishop a dream
okay Brooksie one wasn't very a very
genius idea not I'm not doing this well
the 18 second exchange this is rookin
two points against two pieces this line
is considered to be quite unclear
actually I believe that white is better
at theory a theory is giving unclear on
it but I think why is it better
this is some part of my c4 repertoire
that I've done just 24 I know chasuble
[Music]
let's try to play actively I cannot take
it and now we can maybe get more going
the night were probably moved it was a
good move actually bishop f8 he simply
covered everything I was more more like
a show-off more than anything else and
it doesn't do anything pretty bad
Thanks
I wonder where I should go now I don't
really have great square it's the
problem
yeah I have to take that which wasn't
the plan really not now I've got two
points can you return some stuff
immediately we should pay is pretty
pretty tough to handle
[Music]
Bishop's I extremely dangerous he can
simply take it home
I didn't take you to him hmm beep on is
getting dangerous now ice to do
something about that
well tough game okay pickleback I know
it's too late is it really a good
strategy to tube to berserk or the games
they tend to do that somehow it's not
what I would expect to be right but I
might I might be completely wrong there
of course be working that much
okay and yes I should have seen this
coming
which I didn't pretty awful actually
when attacked there was not a nice thing
to say about the Wesley so DVD I kind of
understand what you're saying but it's
not a prime example of political
correctness my idea
oh that's a good move
was 95
[Music]
yeah is playing well I cannot I only can
hope to do something on time very bad
game
that was pretty awful okay Mickey I
don't think if five is good yeah so I
play conservatively against that he
might claim
yeah I'm somewhat stuck to number 11 I
didn't see me I might make it so many
blunders it's really weird really weird
yeah this set up against f4 has been
promoted in this setup has been promoted
in books in the late 80s Kasparov's
chess openings if you are from Germany
you might know it written by otto boric
and it showed all kinds of openings that
we use by Kasparov it was a pretty cool
book that concept was was recycled some
years later with the opening according
to books according to Anna and according
to hospital to kramnik and so on so I
was really thinking what I'm doing here
is not too bad now I kind of reconsider
I thought I have some good stuff on the
edge file but probably I don't have it
so ship g3 ok ok no Bishop d3 or gage
what doesn't work
this is also not made unfortunately
[Music]
hmm I was totally not working
yeah this is probably not helping but
maybe I have some stuff with d3o no I
have good f5 actually which is just a
bit of help
okay so take here if I take e 3 is this
maybe better
maybe it's a better version I think of
the whole thing
Luke hangs night hangs
d2 hangs so I know it - actually right
why wasn't I really swindled to me what
is swindle I can chick even here no and
check again and that looks like whoever
made somewhere no I wasn't that was a
really major swindle Wow okay fifty five
minutes left so what about the the
leaderboard yeah Taheri has it in the
bag that's pretty much clear and what
can I do if I get some good games and
maybe seventh place or something I would
be a success considering the way it went
probably probably it would be better to
to really berserk a couple of times just
[Music]
the odd game I think would be good too
berserk okay
stop threatening d4 the bishop is
hanging
really I think I don't pre move them I
mostly mostly pre move pretty
extensively my opening moves was the
question why don't I approve I think I
do
he I tried to do something with this
ending
he's got the bishop and that's good but
I've got the better structure thanks for
the follow yeah maybe I could remove
more yes I completely see what you what
you mean
okay Bishop d3 I was rook trapped but I
thought I don't need you do it
immediately
I was a bit surprised to learn that he
did a DVD that he did a DVD M on on one
b3 which he the system it is called my
secret weapon and I don't even recall
that so place this that that was
surprising to me I mean if anybody could
do a DVD oh and then it would be Jabbar
WA or report
maybe Nakamura I mean you wouldn't call
it the secret weapon because they played
all the time but there was still a bit
surprising to me okay that traitor look
see how it would be good it's not so
easy to do
okay I mean I could be wrong there huh
maybe he does play it I mean but I don't
recall I really don't recall him playing
it okay yeah good night who knew tax I
don't really see a good way forward for
me here I cannot move all that much him
just a draw unless like here
this is actually it's still a draw but
now I have slight hopes to continue very
slide admittedly now it was a mistake
for him to trade into this
does the till to continue was that
tilting I don't think I was I mean I was
not really liking my play but I don't
know if chilled is appropriate yeah make
sure you have traded rooks I was a bad
idea I traded the bishop against them
against the night before he simply was
met him
I actually don't think I was tilting I
mean I was playing badly but it didn't
look like kills I mean I know what it is
from playing poker and I really really
act differently if I'm tilting IKEA so
here yeah somehow this seems to be
popular
I said what so said that that this is a
secret weapon that he will never play
it's funny so he really made the made
this DVD and like deliberately chose
something that he will never play and
then I find a really cool idea
[Music]
okay yeah I probably shouldn't have
reserved yeah that's true
I'm surprised that he that white played
into this not that it is so terrible for
whites but he just feels a bit of
awkward and not super necessary to do so
I don't know kind of hoping for queen f
form which is maybe not the best
definitely the best but he can he can
just move the Queen away and it's kind
of a mystery didn't help
I mean yep
feels annoying for for whites but I
honestly kill her too much I have very
little potential to improve my position
h4 o p4 doesn't doesn't really do much
threaten your g3 but it's very obvious
not even sure but it's a real threat
okay
obviously going for
that's your intern now he can go into
the sixth ring as well it's just not
going to be extremely clear
[Music]
keeping those two pawns I lost some time
what what happened oh my I was just
completely ahead on the clock and I
didn't see it then I was getting down
hmm he doesn't have a huge G five years
okay
which didn't happen people don't like
the B's irking and I understand I
already have blundered terribly against
this stuff no terrible terrible
ah Jesus pretty bad I cannot take it
mm I really shouldn't have deserved
sometimes you do it and right afterwards
you kind of see the and I wasn't already
um it was a pretty awful idea
anyway a Scandinavian is a pretty bad
bed opening for white in those
situations if you really don't don't
know it too well and I immediately
screwed some move on up and 111th place
yeah the whole time don't get anywhere
now we have this before this stuff it
was this weird playing with h4 g4 and
kind of peel fling stuff I just wait
with castling okay I know it's not going
to do some weird attack so he actually
knows about castling
yeah that been said white is not in bad
shape
yeah somehow I'm on 11th place the whole
time 95 is meditating but I really
didn't see what else to do no I know
this looks weird but when I thought this
is not so bad
he's got the dark squared Bishop so it's
not so easy for him to take my pawns
does it take
yeah I felt that this is good actually
for me because BD for as weak and b3 is
weak so I don't think this is a huge
issue you know that definitely isn't a
huge issue but I have I've done many of
those I'm going to make a very quick
break be back very soon
you
okay so back for the final 35 minutes
nine nanomachine fifty second place this
is a funny line with 85 26 yeah this is
this is funny I think this is actually
playable for white and there's an
extremely weird variation good that I
didn't berserk that because then I would
certainly lose with this weird position
it's one of those don't try this at home
positions
[Music]
Knight could make a discovery but a
better go away
I think it's still crazy that Taheri is
50 points ahead of everything that's
really really a lot a lot yellow -
she'll arrive I could that you could
join for the final moments there maybe I
should have taken yeah i'm nearing
getting on 10th place now this is a good
square
and he has our time currently to do
anything against it
if you would have taken that he actually
would have lost the Queen I was would be
funny takes 90 to check your luck ween
[Music]
mm yeah taking them doesn't help I would
need to really improve the position a
bit don't see at the moment how this is
kind of an honest but didn't see a hums
that improves so I'm just doing slight
improvements often not a bad strategy in
place if you see something good that
helps you slightly just play it okay it
wasn't great because this is hanging now
not good very unnecessary
a spinal tap reference oh my god this
must been like 20 years since I saw that
one so don't expect me to recognize the
reference it's been a long event for all
of us
you just blundered Vicky
not the big look there yeah so Magnus
wondered young that that match I mean he
had this weird weird time loss so I mean
drawing this is fine of course but
losing so it seems what I can do is
probably get to ninth yeah like maybe
Ronnie I can overtake but that that's it
Jerry will probably get second place
Rick sheave it's an interesting line
that have explored what form I see for
repertoire so I take this rook Knight be
97 is that really it is an issue
resolution 97 no not much that I can do
about it but I'm a pawn up and a fairly
well coordinated position this is
probably the moment where you blunder
stuff yeah it's when you say I have a
fairly coordinated position and then
like oops
first piece second piece there and so on
yeah it should be pretty good for me
this position
yeah it's doing well here to stir up
some trouble really does whoa
very strong
it actually does not work objectively
speaking but it really it really gave me
the creeps a moment Wow yeah after I
capture this it's actually pretty a
pretty well coordinated position
you can check me here but the a pond a
pond is strong very strong
this is attacked and he's attacking on
earth to cover that
everything's covered and if he takes it
a seven eight I'm promoting they have
rope jinhwan shake from a lunatic let's
do that okay oh my
so I to over to karani
I think the last like when I started to
get some points here it was kind of okay
but had this this is this streak which
was really bad which was really bad and
[Music]
yeah
hmm I don't know if I should take this
it could work I was just thinking it's
never going to do this with the time but
maybe maybe I'm I'm too wrong I'm too
relaxed there
so what Shakir
[Music]
now what is okay of course
doesn't help all that much this trick
I'm getting this poem I really don't
like to do that flagging mothers kind of
a weird position like a nothing going on
you just explained that we can every
night I cannot know if I draw anymore
why I really have a this was a bad idea
yeah this is so freeing silly silly I
let him out there
yeah I'm wasting time of course I just I
just I don't know I don't like to Fleck
in those dead positions it just seems
like a complete waste of time
- this click fest no I don't when things
go wrong they really common
[Music]
as a weird weird game weird opening
everything weird okay
and he gets the concentrated so he
doesn't trade and surprising now he
trades cannot rely on people at first he
didn't trade then then he did
we've got 22 seconds it was $1.00
berserk I only see it now I was bad h3
was a lot better okay that was weird
yeah it doesn't change things I probably
get 10th some are more fee 1 2 3 is a
really fantastic streak at one point
just two matches
so probably do I get the Huebner main
the main part of my book it's usually
good news even though I have to say I've
forgotten lots of things I have written
most of this in 2014 so I really have
forgotten a lot
please don't take on h6 this is so
ridiculous if he would if not sure that
I could refute it the way I'm playing
after all those hours ground shakes is
much better he didn't do that
I mean Bishop d3 which is not a huge
threat admittedly let's still do this
try to be a bit of an annoyance
you can go g3 though which is okay yeah
still the bishop on d3 is not helping
him while helping is wrong making life
easier that's what I tried to say the
tournament is on for close to five hours
now oh really okay
he's in a bit of a pin
should g-force the idea which he
prevented
well prevented is wrong but it's a bit
less dangerous now
hmm can I take it why can I not take it
check on edge for tech g5 what's the
deal I don't see why not
what's why can I not take it did I
overlook stuff yeah okay but let's take
this
[Music]
it should be enough stopping everything
and I'm a whole horde of pawns up what a
mammoth tournament yeah that crazy crazy
at least I'm a 10th place I'll get like
a tenth place
[Music]
but I'm playing here might not look
super dangerous but it is not not easy
for for Blackpool there still there's
always an awkward pressure on legs
position I have several particular son
depression sometimes they play but
should be six there and then there I
cannot say and there was no before I
haven't played this ever before this
tournament format so long I mean so I
cannot say if 10th place is good to or
bad on it's about the minimum that what
I thought would happen but I couldn't
really tell how how good depth that
field is it actually was stronger than I
thought that was my idea
asking a question about those pieces
it wasn't very subtle but rook g6 is
almost killing him but not not
immediately rook h6
I would wince and just thinking I have
something quicker in the night yeah she
blundered the night as well which is
funny
I came maybe I can overtake Rania by
soaking I mean I I want some rating
points I started with 2396 pre-move with
some isotonic drinks and bananas okay
yeah I think I mean I think the tea was
fine but it really felt that this is
this long tournament it was really
really long and five I mean it's been
unlucky yeah you berserk you pre-move 96
and the guy plays 2d for the move yeah
which is really where 96 really sucks so
but man
can be three very lucky that he had
their NIDA saying about every I've got
look what what doing
shake on let's do this
[Music]
I take g5 take a - threatening almost
made them I didn't see that I didn't see
that oh my god a knight c6 is obviously
not the best move against e4 I mean if
black takes on d4 is at least equal it's
pretty silly that I'm playing this on
yeah I'm between down ah that didn't
work out yeah four minutes left Lazo and
one point retired from the tournament
right he was also ahead of me most of
the time cycle 46 oh no berserk just
just play one good game and end the
whole thing it's probably the final game
she knows
I really won now people can play like a
five-hour
bullet tournament or five-hour hyper
bullet or something I would be dead I
mean I already feel pretty exhausted I
don't don't know how they do bad relief
yeah thanks for the great feedback it
was a pretty pretty long tournament I'm
definitely I don't know of what 24-hour
tournament I'm I don't think I would be
ready for that
preparing Knight to f5
a knife of five okay stop that for not
sure how danger it is okay so how do I
get to this to this g7 I could just
double what it seems seem slow I try for
a five and maybe Queen g3
preparing a five and maybe Bishop h6 is
the immediate threat hmm
Pusha page six what is he doing g6 then
on a g6 would work
okay III am simply
maybe 94 simply mm-hm it didn't go too
well yeah that doesn't look good yeah
it's got too much too much play on its
own like checking here and everything no
I mean 94 I might be able to take and
and at least try to play still not
totally totally simple and same
I get something here H far looks
dangerous dangerous okay he just goes
for it I thought I would win the Queen
at least how fast is this person this is
crazy
Hey oh you have to you have to do some
time yet
what are you doing wow I wasn't really
thinking like what Wow okay um yeah the
books behind me have chess books which I
have not already but most of them at
least they use most of them okay that
was a marathon like stream it was really
really really long
second place No okay she's networked
beserker 897 I don't know is that a good
strategy I said a good strategy yeah I
don't know
- hurry Joseph 64m they have pretty high
buzzer grades yeah
surviving the tournament yeah
thanks a lot for for watching yeah it is
a really really really really really
long tournament and
a really bad streak in the middle then
the start was good and it got it got
worse and then it was kind of okay yep
tough very tough so um I hope you
enjoyed the stream it was a really long
one and not sure if I'm going to do this
too often it's really really exhausting
okay bye bye guys I'll be back soon